this sunday we're celebrating  international women's day y'all  now don't worry you don't have to  remember to go out and get anyone  flowers  you just have to remember to go out and  fight for equal pay for women in the  workplace now i know there are guys out  there thinking  international women's day why don't we  have an international men's day well  you're in luck because you do it's  actually on november 19th  but you wouldn't know that because  you're too busy celebrating it every  other day of the year  fun fact november 19th is also  international toilet day  now i'm not i'm not saying men are  toilets  but both holidays are mostly catered  towards a bunch of white john's  oh my god  oh my god lord save me deliver me from  this trial just tell one funny joke  that's all i ask